قال وزير الخارجيه التركي مولود شاوش
اوغلو انه سيجتمع مع نظيره السوريين في
النصف الثاني من الشهر الجاري وقالت شاويش
اوغلو في تصريحات غير مصوره خلال عودته من
البرازيل انه سيتم لاحقا تقييم امكانيه
لقاء الرئيسيين التركي والسوري معتبرا ان
من المبكر الحديث عن لقاء يجمع بين
الرئيسين التركي رجب طيب اردوغان وسوري
بشار الاسد وقال ان النظام السوري يريد
التعاون مع تركيا في موضوع عوده السوريين
من تركيا الى سوريا واضاف جوش اوغلو ان
تركيا دوله ضامنه للمعارضه السوريه وانها
لن تطبع مع النظام السوري او تعقد اجتماعا
معه رغما عن المعارضه السوريه او اكد انه
سيجتمع شخصيا مع ممثلي المعارضه السوريه
بعد ظهور اليوم الثلاثاء مشيرا الى ان
مؤسسات الدوله التركيه المختلفه عقدت
اجتماعات لها مع المعارضه السوريه